no one here is saying only hydro I'm not
you're not no one here saying only
nuclear I'm not you're not no one here
saying only fracking I'm not you're not
no one here saying only clean coal I'm
not you're not no one here is even
saying no solar and and noha noha wind
turbines
we're just saying it shouldn't be
subsidized but to the rest of the media
this conversation is that of two
radicals who need to be locked away and
that is concerning to me very happy now
we have a return guest on the program
it's always interesting when you have
people like our next guest because the
video goes up on YouTube and we don't do
a lot of long-form guest interviews yeah
not too often let alone for a second
time and you see this video it goes up
on YouTube of course people who are mug
Club members they enjoyed it but the
people on YouTube their split and you
see a lot of dislikes two likes and then
the ratio just hits a tipping point and
it switches when more people see it and
they actually start looking up what the
guest is actually looking up the stats
of exactly because you know this guy
he's a doctor that means we're all a
bunch of slopes but you can follow him
on the Twitter as long as they allow him
at eco sense now his book is confessions
of a Greenpeace dropout dr. Patrick
Moore thank you for being back sir great
Steven nice to be with you again well I
I'm really glad to have you back because
there were a couple of things I wanted
to talk about and I know that you wrote
an article about twelve and visible eco
catastrophes and threats of doom that
are actually fake I'd like to get to
those in a second but last time we had
you on first off did you get a lot of
feedback from urine and your in your
private inboxes or did you check out the
comments section do you just avoid it no
I generally do look at the comments
section and it was quite a lot of
comments you're right there was some
negatives at first knee-jerk stuff and
trolls but in the end it came out very
positive because I am telling the truth
and if anybody can find something that
I'm saying that they don't think is true
I would be very pleased to hear from
them so I can correct it the comments
switched because immediately people have
a knee-jerk reaction like you said they
go oh this person is this person is a
climate denier [ __ ] dislike until I
realized on a second one of the founding
members of Greenpeace a doctor somebody
who's actually study this extensively
and then people started listening to
what you
to say and I wanted to have you on for
for something specific that I noticed
you know I spend a lot of times and a
lot of time in the Great Lakes regions
and you know there but record-high is
right now remember dick Durbin in 2013
saying they were gonna dry up and fast
for a few years some of them I think are
at record highs and I know others are at
17-year highs and in contrast what we
talked about with climate change
wherever people line up personally the
region has had some of the best growing
climates in decades cherries are very
finicky crop that's one thing that I
know because we have family who work in
cherries and it needs a very moderate
slow thawing winter and they've actually
had to dump cherries to price fix so
right away I thought of you when we
discussed climate change a warming
climate and more precipitation have you
been following this and I always wonder
what the response is from the alarmists
regardless of where they line up on
climate change but the alarmism Africa
on a second the lakes are high and
growing is fantastic well they'll find
some reason to say that it's bad that
the lakes are overflowing etc you know I
mean because now it's become that
climate change is too hot and it's too
cold and it's too wet and it's too dry
and then they make up that there's more
tornados and hurricanes which is false
and then they make up that there's more
damage being caused by extreme weather
which is true because there's so much
more infrastructure in the way of
extreme winter today because of the
population growth and the growth of
cities and all so they'll find a way
every time to point to something that
they claim is out of the ordinary and I
have challenged these people in a
general sense that there is nothing
absolutely zero nothing in today's
weather or climate that is anywhere near
out of line with the last 10,000 years
in this interglacial period since the
ice caps melted the last time and so
they've got to say ok no there's a
strongest this and the strongest that or
the weakest this and the week is that
they can't because nothing that is
happening now is anywhere near out of
ordinary with the ordinary well that is
just there's extremes in every measure
you'll always find an extreme somewhere
in the world
going on and that's all they do is
cherry-pick them now and it's really
disingenuous of them because they
started saying it's global warming and
carbon dioxide is doing it it was very
simple what they said at the beginning
sure more co2 from human fossil fuel
consumption will increase the warming of
the earth then they changed it to
climate change which now wasn't just
warming it was also cold yes and rasa
and and and wet and every other
imaginable flooding and whatever all of
a sudden was attributable to carbon
dioxide even cold was attributable to
carbon dioxide even though the idea of
co2 being a greenhouse gas is the idea
that it would make it warmer right not
that it would make it colder and then
when the temperature stopped increasing
at the rate it did during the 1990s
wasn't we both acknowledge it was
happening was it it was increasing 1990s
yes there you go there's four people out
there's not a desire he's actually
analyzing the data we both agree on that
good this 1990s warming its beginning in
actually the 80s followed the cooling
from the 1940s to the 1970s in which if
you go to the deplorable climate science
blog of Tony Heller's you will see just
yesterday on the 10th of this month he
documented what they were saying that
now new age may be coming because it was
cooling in the 60s and 70s yes then it
started warming again and around 2000
the warming slowed down to are basically
insignificant level well I believe we've
cut I don't want to I don't want to cut
you but I believe we've covered this
quite a bit in the first interview and
it was very interesting and of course
there's still backlash no matter what my
my point of interest here is with the
Great Lakes it's moderate temperate
climate climates not super cold and not
super hot in the summers slow thawing
and record crop yields for the probe
over dumping cherries out because we
want to fix the prices it to me it is
mind-boggling but this does bring us to
a bigger point which you wrote about in
your article um what do you think of the
new trend I you know what maybe I'm
ignorant maybe it's not a new trend but
it seems as though science right now is
bowing to activism quite a bit and
that's kind of what you're speaking
about where where where science is often
used to silence
whatever contradicts its initial
hypothesis and a good example this is
right now if people are watching this on
YouTube I don't know if you're where
this YouTube now puts fat check links on
all videos about people who might be
climate change skeptics as they put them
in order to debunk them so right now it
could be appearing I have no idea what
point in this video what do you think
about science bowing to political
pressure is that a real problem yes it
is a real problem like when Galileo was
put under house arrest for his life for
saying that the earth went around the
Sun and the same thing is happening now
people are claiming that co2 is the main
driver of climate change global warming
and now it isn't even climate change
it's extreme weather events they used to
say oh that's not climate that's just
the weather when you said oh it was
really cold or read something you know
that that's sort of contradicted right
the global warming scenario and and now
all they do is talk about extreme
weather when they were telling us not to
confuse weather with climate yes years
ago it was used to actually make people
look like it make anybody look like a
simpleton they go oh you're confusing
climate and weather and of course I
ruined Thanksgiving dinner did you have
you heard that by the way the recent a
good example of the hoax academic paper
it claimed that penises cause climate
change were you up on this I did hear
about that and I looked down and could
not see any causal relationship at all
well yes it's more of it's more of a
climate detector it's a veritable
climate psychic interchangeably but it's
it's pretty funny they just used a bunch
of climate jargon to associate penises
with worsening climate change but the
funny part I don't think I'll ever will
know about this it actually was
published in her peer-reviewed academic
journal they were tricked that to me is
I mean that really is Orwellian type
scary as a non scientist well you know
at my age actually Steven any cause
effect relationship related to that part
of my anatomy would be welcome that's
AII
there'll be a different doctor who I'll
have on on a private Skype after this
but I mean how does that happen how does
something like this someone who's been
in this industry for a long time and
obviously the work that you've done as a
doctor how does something like this get
pop we always talk about peer-reviewed
papers
in a peer-reviewed journals how does
something that was fraudulent by design
make it through what's the process like
Howard it screaming it's completely
corrupted in that almost all the
peer-review is being done by people's
buddies who are on the same wavelength
as they are and and actually most of the
peer review journals have been taken
over by journalists used to be peer
reviewed science journalists were run by
scientists who had a flair for
publishing and for the language and you
know could read and write but these
these people in charge of the science
journals now are leftist journalists to
a large extent and they just have a
barrier against anything that questions
the litany or the the truth squad and as
they call themselves but they're not the
truth squad they're they don't let the
truth out squad this has been I'm on the
west coast of British Columbia here this
has been one of the biggest wild berry
years I have seen it is actually the
biggest one I've ever seen black
blackberries which are gone wild here
they're not native to here huckleberry
salmon berries salal berries those are
all native here I've never seen anything
like it and it isn't just the warmth as
a matter of fact I think the warming is
a minor component of the record crop
productions that are going on in greens
and all kinds of other commodities
around the world
it's the increase in carbon dioxide
which is fertilizing all of the green
plants around the world and making them
grow faster and yield more that's the
biggest part of it and it's been more or
less proven with satellites from about
six different research groups around the
world in Europe in Australia in the
United States and a bad fact is a bit of
a disconnect in NASA and NOAA because
there are people in both those
organizations who are looking at the
fertilization effect of co2 on the
greening of the earth as it's called the
earth know it already
a quick question I'm a simpleton would
that be directly just because of co2 s
chemical structure are you talking about
it leading to more precipitation which
would help obviously with the soil no
I'm talking about it as a food for
plants co2 is the primary food for
plants right water is it
is also like carbon dioxide and water
put together Nick sugar glucose that's
the basis of the energy for all life on
earth because we have to we eat the
plants or we eat animals that have eaten
the plants it all comes up from
photosynthesis and the combination of
carbon dioxide and water to make sugar
and this is where the demonization of
carbon dioxide is so outrageously
off-base because carbon dioxide is the
basis of all organic life on earth that
is where the carbon comes from in
carbon-based life and we are
carbon-based life and so is all the rest
of the life on Earth and if there wasn't
any co2 in the global atmosphere there
would be no life not only not only if
there wasn't any if there wasn't a
certain amount because just like
anything there can be too little of that
that's my pivotal question here because
I can hear skeptics right now saying
well holla second we're not saying all
carbon dioxide is bad we're saying that
we are out of balance now that the ratio
is too high of carbon dioxide so what is
the amount that would be optimal I guess
and and how close or how far away are we
from because I know that that's where a
lot of the nuance debate occurs and they
just claim that obviously non scientist
as myself are not entitled to an opinion
so I'll listen to yours well one of the
most concrete ways in which you can see
what the optimum level for plant growth
is is both experimentation in labs and
greenhouse growers all greenhouse
growers around the world increased the
co2 level in their greenhouse to
increase the productivity up to 40 to 60
percent of the crops in there and to
make them grow faster to come to
fruition sooner shorter time of growth
and other words and that that's around
800 to 2000 parts per million now
greenhouse growers don't put 2,000 ppm
in because there's a law of diminishing
returns at first you get really great
increases from 400 to 800 and even from
800 to a thousand or 1200 after that the
curve starts to go off but it still goes
up okay so in nature where they're not
worried about profits and diminishing
returns in nature the optimum level is
somewhere between 1,000 and 3,000 parts
per million whereas now it's
400 and before we came along it was 280
and at the height of the last glaciation
because the Seas when they cool absorb
co2 from the atmosphere it was at 180
parts per million which is only 30 parts
per million above where plants begin to
die at 150 ppm and during the last
glaciation the high elevation plants did
die that is pretty well demonstrated and
the reason they died is because the
higher you go the thinner the air
becomes and so a hundred and fifty parts
per million is occupying a much larger
volume elevation and therefore the
plants get get enough co2 to survive so
we were talked about not being in
balance
co2 has been declining for 150 million
years on a relatively steady basis right
you can the Japs are all available for
anybody to see and it's very well proven
through ice cores and oxygen-18 proxies
in ocean sediments and etc etc
Stonehenge has been declining steadily
actually for the last 500 million years
but let's just take the last 150 million
where it has been steadily declining
without any upward blips there was a
huge flux of co2 into the atmosphere in
the early Earth then when species
learned to do photosynthesis and use
that carbon dioxide to make sugars they
started taking it out of the atmosphere
but it wasn't until about 40 or 50
million years ago that it started to go
into a danger zone and it just keeps
going down and down and down until we
came along whereas the marine calcifying
organisms inadvertently by building an
armor plating for themselves a very
useful thing to do for their survival
presage the end of life on earth through
the loss of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere over time Al Gore has another
Learjet to get to I do I understand
exactly where you're what you're going
with this but here's kind of that the
issue that we run into right is what
you're saying obviously what will have
overlays for people people can look up
for themselves and obviously decide
whether they believe it to be legitimate
or not there's something that is
legitimate there's truth and then you
can choose to believe truth
unfortunately but but the issue is that
everything you're saying doesn't break
through and so
even YouTube like we just talked about
themselves will dismiss you simply as a
quack as a denier without listening to
what you have to say so I want to go
back to something you just mentioned
which to me is obviously at most
importance because it ties into a lot of
the cultural issues that we've discussed
cultural Marxism the censorship of
speech we see it in comedy now but it
really concerns me when you start to see
it in science you mentioned that a lot
of these peer-reviewed journals were
once peer reviewed by scientists and now
often by activists journalists activists
scientists or active scientists yes
journalists control the journals
yes large these days the activists
control the science of a call right when
they say climate science right or
climate scientists they mean themselves
yes they don't mean and everybody who's
studying the climate because people who
are studying the climate who don't agree
with them are considered deniers not
climate scientists exactly I'm talking
about the peer-reviewed journals like we
were discussing and you said there's
been a shift that when did that shift
occur because it for a long time again
Americans had to rely on certain systems
and power that they believed to be
truthful when would you say that shift
occurred and do you have any I guess
particularly breeds of examples that we
could mitigating thirty years ago twenty
years ago it was over by you know 20
years ago pretty well and and that's
what we've been being fed since is
basically a very filtered set of ideas
the idea that co2 is the main driver of
climate change and global warming is
this the center piece right and and it
is that is false there is no possibility
that any substance in that small
quantity point zero four percent of the
atmosphere could be the controlling
factor of the whole global climate the
Sun is the controlling factor of the
whole global climate but it is moderated
by many other and classic questions you
said as you said point four percent how
much of that is zero or per 20 or more
percent how much of that is human is men
made well that's a question of whether
you're looking at it as how much of the
co2 in the atmosphere today was caused
by humans versus
the co2 in the flux is caused by humans
right it sorts like in economics you
have a cash flow statement and you have
a balance sheet on the balance sheet
right now co2 has gone from 280 parts
per million to 400 parts per million
about a 40% increase since humans
started and missing significant amounts
of co2 mostly since 1950 has been an
exponential curve of emissions but there
hasn't really been an exponential curve
of co2 levels in the atmosphere that's a
fairly straight line and that indicates
that much of the co2 we are emitting is
being absorbed by the vegetation because
that's that's what eats co2 that's what
I wanted to get to because that to me is
I think this is kind of a bait and
switch that occurs with a lot of people
again being someone who's not a
scientist but who's read as best I can
yeah there has been there have been
drastic increases certainly in human
emissions but like you said I think it's
very interesting if people look it up
and see that as you've just discussed
the overall levels of co2 in the Earth's
climate do not necessarily necessarily
correlate they've been pretty consistent
and that to me was one of the most
remarkable findings during my research
into this issue and I just highly
encourage that everyone else out there
go in and do that research let me let me
ask you I want to go back to the
journalism issue because again this is
very input doesn't matter we can we can
scream until we're blue in the face
about the truth if no one is there to
hear it if we get shut down and that's
where the deep platforming is is so
dangerous why do you think it is why did
this happened what happened that now
this will definitely be demonetized why
did this happen with peer-reviewed
journals I mean a good example we kind
of see it right now with the BDSM or you
know brown just remove the study on
rapid onset gender dysphoria for example
they removed an actual study an actual
yoora Telma clinical studies medical
observations we kind of see what's
happening there for example on the
gender science dead of political
correctness but why do you think this
occurred starting 30 years ago according
to your kind of approximation why what's
what is the why here behind this and
this trend this transition so recently
well they're the the real
is there are five powerful elites in our
society who benefit from this myth no
can emit the carbon dioxide da da da and
and it depends on which five or six
depending on whether you think the media
and Hollywood are two separate elites or
whether they are one le right but
starting at the top with the green
movement itself the fundraising around
this issue has been hundreds of billions
of dollars over the years then you come
to the politicians who benefit from the
idea that they can save the citizens
from this catastrophe
right right catastrophe is made up by
the green movement and the media
basically being an echo chamber for it
the media needs sensationalism
especially the print media these days
but all media is giving in to Internet
these days so turn the big media
mainstream media is all under threat
right because of digital media internet
media's social media all that stuff a
proper example there for people by the
way doubting just to back up what you're
saying your cherries are a good example
because only a few years ago in northern
Michigan this I experienced this
personally remember the trees thought
right there was a thought and then it
froze again later you know as a later
winter freezing and so there was a
horrible for the cherry crop and it was
all over the news
record high share yields to the point
that they're dumping cherries not a peep
you have to do a lot of research to find
that out because it doesn't sell papers
as much as cherries might be gone due to
climate change we actually read those
articles if you go and read the local
Michigan publication so I just wanted to
drive that one home because I'm sure a
lot of people can think of specific and
solely in their life so we've got the
green movement the media and the
politicians who can promise to save
people from certain doom right and their
children and their grandchildren of
course para sacar Indian and then
there's the green businesses Elon Musk
mm-hmm right Tesla and all of that we're
not going to like this but could you
think you already hear the comments the
wind and solar short Tesla right now
because he's done far as I'm concerned
same with wind and solar the vast
quantities of money and tax credits and
subsidies and guaranteed profits that
have gone into these to prop them up it
would never have happened otherwise in
any world there is it's completely
stupid what's been done if people want
clean energy they should go nuclear and
hydro electric where it is available
right let's toot and gas clean gas and
now clean coal because they have learned
with scrubbers and precipitators and all
of these technologies to make the
exhaust coming out from a coal plant
very clean from a pollution point of
view but they call co2 a pollutant when
in fact it is the main food for all life
on Earth
we need to separate those two things
separate how about separating
poison from primary nutrient of all life
on earth that would be a logical
separation as far as I'm concerned and
then it seems then come when you put it
that way yes then comes the scientists
virtually all of whom in the climate
scientist category as they like they
self-described cleek of climate
scientists are almost all I would almost
say a hundred percent close to a hundred
percent on taxpayer money there's a
hundred billion dollar climate fund that
you know the first guy line up for it
after the Paris agreement was Mugabe
from Zimbabwe
right and he claimed that climate change
had destroyed the agricultural industry
in Zimbabwe it might have had something
to do with him kicking out all the
people who actually knew how to farm
could it could be related yes there
could be some correlation there I'll
give you that
but in case of the Paris agreement it's
just a goody-two-shoes document it has
nothing to do with anything that is
actually going to happen because I'm
never assuming by the way that's
assuming that you believe carbon dioxide
to be poison and it's assuming by the
way that you believe if everyone
followed the rules that it would somehow
fix this problem of climate change if
you assume those things then you can
look at this bill of course which which
would cost countries billions upon
billions of dollars not to mention the
millions of lives in third-world
countries
you also have to go along the logic
trail assuming that China's gonna play
ball yeah we'll get right on that
the only that's their top priority right
now they were actually specifically
exempted along with India right from the
beginning Obama over to China and
negotiated a historic climate deal with
the Chinese that they wouldn't have to
do anything until 2030 which might as
well be infinity why well because they
wanted to vote for it
if you would what might should they get
to vote and emit a lot they're
completely exempt I understand that's
why we wanted them to vote they had vote
because they were one of the countries
in the world yes I know they're one of
the countries in the world but they're
not going to pull themselves out of this
agreement to meet as it is it's like
having a current shellin who is in
prison voting on the laws of felonies it
is unreal to me and the reason I'm
saying yes
does it sound absurd I'm trying to make
the point that people need to understand
we needed the vote of a country who had
no plan in taking part in the law to
begin with that is nonsensical to me
even if you believe everything else
leading up to that point and I think
most people don't even know this there
is no evidence that any country I mean
any not one country has made an effort
to live up to the Paris agreement right
none they're all just going about their
business as usual the United States in
fact has reduced its co2 emissions since
the year 2000 more than any other
country in the world you know without
any Paris Accord or Kyoto Protocol and
that's largely because of the conversion
from coal to gas due to the fracking
industry and the Greens are against
fracking along with nuclear energy which
has no co2 emissions and hydroelectric
energy apparently they don't like Lakes
are too many leaves yeah exactly
that leads to obviously their issues
with dams that leads to Tom Selleck
stealing water for his avocados I grew
up in Quebec well people would say we
pay our hydro bill that frequent hydro
was our electric bill so when we first
would move there oh you're paying your
water but no hydro electric we even had
a problem with it and you have
socialists and socialist separatists in
Quebec there are no far right-wing
conspiracy theorists they don't exist
and I do think it's important what
you're talking about what I have heard
you and then I want to get to your
article in just a couple of top examples
of these sort of doomsday threats that
we've been hearing from the media for a
long time I thought some of them were
hysterical the ones that you debunked
but what I'm hearing from you is first
off a very balanced worldview and
approach you you acknowledge the warming
you acknowledge that human emissions
have increased but then a disagreement
on whether it is poison or actually a as
we're talking about carbon dioxide
life-giving for plants in a lot of ways
and then I hear a very multi-pronged
approach and this is something I think
people need to understand to be a
climate change denier or skeptic to be
labeled that just means that you have to
disagree with any of these points for
example even if we agreed with
everything else even if I disagreed with
you on the carbon dioxide and I just
said you know what though I don't think
that the Paris agreement is going to
work out swing be labeled a climate
change denier and you are also talking
about a very multi-pronged approach no
one here is saying only hydro I'm not
you're not no one here saying only
nuclear I'm not you're not no one here
saying only fracking I'm not you're not
no one here saying only clean coal I'm
not you're not no one here is even
saying no solar and and noha noha
wind turbines we're just saying it
shouldn't be subsidized but to the rest
of the media this conversation is that
of two radicals who need to be locked
away and that is concerning to me yeah
it should be because unless you believe
every single word of what they're saying
they can call you a denier Rand that
means it's more like Nazi it's more like
Stalin it's more like the dictatorships
that have destroyed countries like
Venezuela it's it's it's wrong to
destroy freedom of thought and freedom
of speech and they're doing this in the
name of I don't know they they make they
make it out as if they're the ones that
are in favor of freedom of speech almost
and yeah they're not the racists you
know right of course not except they
don't like white people it's so weird
it's so weird and when anyone ever says
anything about someone and they're
saying it's because of their race I'm
just going like what the hell are you
talking about you can't say
that everybody of that race is this way
or that way right
you know there's smart people in every
race there's stupid people in every race
they're short and tall people in every
race and that's another issue we're just
talking about this with sheriff Clark
today that's been politicized by science
for example we know I mean listen we
talked about the difference between
races there's a reason look at the top
ten land speed records from anything on
two feet either there's not a white
person there there are no Greek names in
there just look at the world strong and
spent they all come from Iceland it's an
eye it's a place with 300,000 people
obviously there's a difference in
lineages obviously people have certain
proclivities to being and usually
there's a life budget where you're
better in one area then somebody else
has got you got you checkmate it in
another one okay but I didn't not sex no
not well sex is a figment of your
imagination it's all about gender now
yeah you just want to ensure that this
gets banned and demonetised so you wrote
this article at what's up with that calm
twelve invisible eco catastrophes and
threats of Doom's that are actually fake
if you could just for people who haven't
read it I highly recommend they go read
it will have a we'll have it linked in
the description what are some of the
prime examples that you think people
what where people might have some miss
construed ideas they're all actually
pretty prime the basis of this though is
that invisible and remote tracks right
and what it means is that these twelve
ones and there's more of them are all
about things that nobody can verify for
themselves by observation because they
are either invisible or way far away and
the first one in there is the coral
reefs are dying mm-hmm right coral reefs
are way far away from nearly everybody
and they are under the water where no
one can actually verify what's happening
so when it was broadcast far and wide in
2016 that 93 percent of the Great
Barrier Reef was dead or dying or about
to die soon that viral around the world
the actual statistic that was based on
was that 93 percent of the reefs in the
northern hottest region compared to the
central and southern so those three
regions 93 percent of the reefs in the
northern Reed
had some bleaching yes that could be one
percent out of the 93 percent of the
reefs could mean they're big savvy fans
and the fact is bleaching is not death
bleaching is just a stage the coral goes
through when it D jex it symbionts its
phytoplankton which makes it what color
it is and it turns white because the
organisms that live in the coral are in
fact clear like a jellyfish they are
related to jellyfish they're the same
basic family okay and so so this this
goes around the world then when it's
turn it turns out very clearly two years
later that all these reefs are
recovering and they never were dead in
the first place no news goes with that
just like that it's dumping of the
cherries we hear about the frozen
cherries you don't hear about all the
delicious ones that you're dumping in a
pot because if the price fix because its
current is the sea plastic right okay
this is one that I just had someone in
the office telling me the other day
talking about the sea of platt out out
in the middle of the ocean the size of
Texas right yes you couldn't you
couldn't film that from an aircraft at
80,000 feet it's so big right you would
go in a geosynchronous satellite 30,000
miles above the earth to get something
as big as Texas in the lens practically
right and and and what I first thing I
say is have you seen a picture of this
on the internet anywhere this sea of
plastic the size of Texas no it's all
graphics right no pictures of it there's
a picture of a bird laying a dead bird
cut open where they have placed plastic
objects in it so that it's more than a
stomach could hold right it's totally
fake and it's all over the internet that
this bird ate all is plastic and died
right right the reason the reason fish
and birds eat pieces of plastic is not
because of the plastic it's because of
the food that is growing on the plastic
just like a piece of wood would have
barnacles and crabs and stuff growing on
it that's why they eat it and what
species would swallow something bigger
than it could poop oh great if they're
if we could swallow something bigger
than we could poop out we'd all be dead
because my dog did that once he
swallowed an entire ear of corn hole
yeah and then the next day went right on
the table so
I wouldn't put it past some species but
that is now what what again devil's
advocate here
what if would people argue a hole or
something that's actually one day there
is no sea of plastic but if you added up
the totality of plastic would it make up
the size of you know the state of Texas
or Roseanne's loft apartment not if it
was all crunched together and all
wouldn't and there's this island in the
Pitcairn group that they say has the
most plastic of any island in the
Pacific okay in the world right so what
is Connecticut - you can't even fly to
it it hasn't got an airport it's
uninhabited so I went on Google Earth
and you can actually go right down to
see all the beaches around and you
cannot see anything there right it's
right on Google Earth I'm doing it I'm
redoing my main presentation to reflect
these twelve fake catastrophe it's more
like Rhode Island's sized see if plastic
here's what you're telling us of places
where plastic is coming out rivers and
clogging up estuary especially in Asia
yeah for some reason they have a
penchant for throwing plastic in the in
the river yeah I don't so and and and in
in in in Eastern Europe the the
communities of gypsies throw all their
garbage out the back door and it ends up
in the streams and lakes and it's a
problem that really it's mostly a
problem of litter yeah plastic it's no
more toxic than wood right it's not
toxic your credit cards are made of
plastic vinyl records were made of
plastic
you've probably got plastic things
sitting on your desk in front of the
arguments is that's unnatural that wood
was kind of a natural cycle of nature
that would it would need to make its way
out into the open water whereas plastic
is new because of humans so they would
say because it's unnatural that comes
with problems except wood is also a
plastic the lignin in wood is a plastic
cellulose was nature's first plastic
it's a of glucose molecules yeah so very
difficult to digest by the way I found
that out for my nutritionist of
cellulose she was Leo actually a lot of
raw vegetables aren't really all that
good for you because cellulose can be
pretty tough from the digestive tract
and I learned that one the hard way but
yes okay so there's no they say fiber is
good for your digestive system even
though you can't
digest it but best to put it through a
cow first because they can't digest it
actually the cows aren't digesting it
it's bacteria in their gut yes and the
bacteria in their gut have fungi inside
them that produce the actual enzyme that
is able to split the glucose molecules
from a cellulose doctor I love you but
you're getting too nerdy okay let's go
to the next catastrophe here don't eat
wood yeah don't eat wood okay this is
one obviously we've talked about this
polar bears that's that's one that the
filament McLaren and McIlhenny have
talked about for a long time I mean okay
can they give us that one along with the
Great Lakes record highs can they give
us the polar bears and say they were
wrong about that no they cannot even
though they admit that the polar bear
population has increased substantially
they questioned the number from 1970 at
being 6,000 so they say I don't know it
couldn't have been that low back then
actually it was because it was
unrestricted hunting on polar bears
until 1972 when the United States and
all the other circumpolar countries
signed a treaty restricting hunting on
polar bears since then they have
increased to 25 to 30,000 from whatever
it was back then but it's a big increase
and virtually all the populations are
stable or growing but that's a nightmare
why don't you just go look for yourself
just go up and count the polar bears
around the Arctic Circle it's nothing to
it alright that's problem that's the
problem with these twelve invisible and
threats that do them they're either
they're either invisible like carbon
dioxide that counts for about five of
them ocean acidification all this
climate stuff you know increased storms
is all caused by this
minut invisible gas in the atmosphere oh
yes right and we believe in witchcraft
too given so well people don't know
after this me and dr. Patrick Moore we
have a good leeching with each other
we're gonna be doing a lot of leaching
so no I do the polar bears no one can go
and verify it for themselves how many
there are they have to listen to
scientists sometimes activist scientists
on public money they have to listen to
activists politicians they have to
listen to green activists all of whom
are in a cabal trying to
population has increased it will sure
passion to oblivion
Idina right it's all about predictions
for these people yeah an Al Gore
predicted to be no ice in the summer in
the Arctic way before now I know that
wasn't seven I know it's remarkable
again dick durbin with the Great Lakes
drying up I was looking at the whole I
was looking at the Lake Michigan
coastline going okay this is one that
people can verify for themselves look
that used to be Beach we don't have
beach there anymore can you give us this
one but polar bears I hate I'd be fine
if they went extinct I know you're not
supposed to say that but they're one of
the only species who actually hunt
humans for fun in the face in the with
availability right really available
actually other food sources they will
eat humans I don't like them and paper
straws suck I think this is this is
emblematic and then we can leave on this
and I will get your thoughts your the
plastic straw controversy okay obviously
this isn't as serious as people dying in
third-world countries due to energy
concerns with modern climate activism
but the plastic straw debacle here's
what is so amazing to me when someone
first sat down and pitched the idea of a
paper straw right before this was this
was foisted on the American public you
would think there'd be a conversation of
lajas again how do we improve this
because right everyone here think right
now think of a paper straw you would
think it's soggy it sucks
it's ain't you know you're everything
you drink through this straw your
cocktail tastes like a number-two pencil
you would think all of these things and
you would think that the people who
thrust this idea forward of paper straws
instead of plastic would have solved
them no it's exactly what you think it's
like they don't care how inconvenient
its heritable it terrible it is for
humans that's why I hate the paper straw
controversy because they suck your
thoughts well the real issue is what on
earth harm is the plastic straw causing
they make fake pictures of marine
animals with straws sticking out of
their eyes as you know I mean it's
completely phony straws are not
dangerous what's dangerous is castaway
fishnets it's it's not because they're
made of plastic it's because of the
shape they're in right it's because of
their configuration you could make a net
out of organic
and put it out in the ocean and it would
catch things too
yeah so what we have to do is teach
fishermen not to discard their worn-out
necks and to come sell them to somebody
on the beach because people don't mind
if they got a few holes in them and put
them over there roof and stuff like that
there's a big market in used fish nets
in fact right so so people should should
learn I mean there's lots of education
required around our interaction with the
environment and but we have to
differentiate between litter and
pollution pollution is toxic pollution
causes harm litter by the side of the
road a pop bottle by the side of the
road is not going to cause harm my
Greenpeace buddies back in the day used
to be aghast when I would throw tin cans
and and glass bottles overboard out in
the middle of the Pacific because I knew
they would become a habitat for some
creature on the bottom right and they're
not gonna harm anything right somewhere
right now there's a hermit crab wearing
your old Dr Pepper bottle I think this
perfectly no none of us want we don't
want more litter and obviously it hurts
your property values of course that's my
primary concern here but yeah I think we
want to be we want to be good stewards
of what what we've been endowed with
what we have obviously you don't want to
be careless with the environment or with
littering when it's needless but I
really appreciate you come on the show
and educating us hopeful for those who
have ears to hear eek at eco sense now
on Twitter the book is confessions of a
Greenpeace dropout and it's available
paperback or ebook on Amazon right dr.
Patrick Norton
it's and my website is eco cents dot nee
eco cents dot me and that article will
have the descriptions that what's up
with that com
the very entertaining very educational
well birth read doctor thank you so much
for being a left have you back again if
you like this video subscribe hit the
notification bell or if you want to
continue to enjoy free content support
us at allotted with credit com /mo club
where you get the full nightly show an
hour every day free along with all of
our friends content if not you don't
wanna do any of those things you're
probably just here you're watching me
seething you came here to hate watch
that being said the internet was created
for people like you